I'm Justine I'm 22 and I've been doing
parkour about 25 years
parkour takes a lot of agility and a lot
of training hi I'm Desiree I've been
doing parkour for 25 years now it's been
a long road but I've learned so much a
long way
buckle has helped you know in my daily
life I meal to cook better I'm able to
sleep more you know I'm able to run
faster you know the other day I just I
saved a baby's life we do parkour
anywhere that we can rain or snow
it just becomes such an important thing
in our lives and just really over the
years we just improve so much and our
agility and our strength and Justine has
just been able to to jump over buildings
yeah
actually when I came out of my mom I did
a cat grab right on the doctors face and
that's when I knew you know it's a story
that a lot of people were talking about
they knew Justine she's gonna be good in
parkour she knows what she's doing every
time we get together it's just a new
thing a new jump we learn anything at
all I mean just look at her she's so
good it takes a lot of strength agility
a lot of training a lot of stuff that we
do is used in movies we do a lot of
stunt work we worked with a lot of great
trainers to help us get to the point
that we're at right now not even believe
what all goes into this until you really
research it and then it can be as
knowledgeable as we are parkour is
something that has changed my life it's
like an everyday life
I see a flight of stairs I don't you
know it wouldn't be with the help of
everyone around us she's been you know
letting us jump on their buildings jump
on their children anything at all we
just we just jump on things and we just
become so good at that sometimes people
don't even see us we're just we're
invisible